una nueva redada del ejército israelí
aumenta la tensión en las discordancia
ocupada territorio palestino bajo
control de Israel en la madrugada de
este jueves dos palestinos murieron y
otros resultó herido durante una redada
de las fuerzas israelíes en la ciudad de
yenín así lo anunció el Primer Ministro
saliente Yair la pide en su cuenta de
Twitter
la actividad de las fuerzas de defensa
de Israel y las fuerzas de seguridad
esta noche en yenín es una continuación
directa de nuestra política
intransigente en la lucha contra el
terrorismo los dos oficiales frustrados
un comandante en terreno de llenín y
miembro de la yihat islámica y otro
miembro de alto Rango de las brigadas al
Axa planearon y llevaron a cabo ataques
en terreno israelí
la organización Palestina yihadi
islámica reconoció que los dos hombres
asesinados por Israel eran sus
militantes sus nombres eran muhammad
aimán al sadi de 26 años y naim yamal
survidee de 27
entre lamentos y lágrimas familiares y
lugareños asistieron a los funerales
ceremonias que no estuvieron exentas de
enfrentamientos entre civiles palestinos
y el ejército israelí el malestar en
cisjordania crece luego de intensas
redadas esta semana que han dejado
muertos heridos y han afectado incluso a
campos de refugiados este año ha sido el
más violento en Palestina en 16 años
según el Ministerio de sanidad es la
autoridad nacional Palestina
158 palestinos han sido asesinados por
Israel en 2022 muchos de ellos civiles
la situación en las es Jordania ocupada
podría empeorar ahora con un gobierno
extrema derecha en Israel tras la
victoria de Benjamín en las últimas
elecciones